je sais que je voulais faire une
surprise ce soir on a vu ta photo classe
avec on va avoir ta photo classe et
c'est vrai que voilà on vous invite est
ton meilleur pote de l'époque c'était en
tout cas ça ça c'est un vrai repas
première exactement david 17 ans en
première j'avais 29 ans et dont et donc
tu avais tu as un super pote qui
s'appelait stefan wey et y avait un
autre que je n'aimais pas du tout donc
allons-y alors je veux dire le nom de
famille oui publicis est le bon pote
mais pas le pote qu'on a fait venir
c'est stéphane richard laissez pas le
nom n'est pas très envie de le voir
franchement fait moi ça sympa alors il
nous a dit je viens je te promets il
nous a dit que c'était un super pote à
toi non c'est pas de super pote cgt ou
là je sais pas si on peut appeler ça du
harcèlement et tout voilà au genre du
tout de mettre le jeu elle est on est à
allah je mange à la cantine le midi et
ce jour là on s'est complètement
couillon mais c'est la vérité il ya du
court bouillon lors et prend le court
bouillon
il me leblanc c'est la gueule me fait
rire tout le monde et commence à gueuler
courbet court-bouillon jusque là y'a
rien d'extraordinaire chez mais il
commençait à faire comme c'est un
courbet coin tu as lens a vraiment tout
le réfectoire qui commence à faire
couvert ça pourrait s'arrêter là sauf
que c'était tous les jours dans la cour
dans l'école tout le temps c'est à dire
que je n'ai pas parlé à mes parents je
n'allais plus à la cantine le midi parce
que c'était l'humiliation
donc j'étais obligé avait que de bouffer
des morceaux de pain et je me suis barré
à ce terminal pour paraissait alors si
je peux éviter de quoi si je peux éviter
de le voir ces marchands c'est l'autre
[Rires]
[Musique]
c'est très triste
c'est quoi cette blague
cette démarche est non parce que y'a
normes il ya des gens mais je suis bien
je viens justement non il ya des gens
qui vivent des trucs très grave et des
enfants non plus et ça commence comme ça
avec tous ces barbus à l'humour et hop
voilà mais euh là on se sert de sa mine
d'or à julien pour dire n'hésitez pas à
en parler
les chéris c'est très important et voilà
il te vas n'est en fait voilà il tapait
courbet pour boulot il a fallu cinq ans
pour le barça s'est pas non plus fait
donc stéphane pichon mais n'était ce
n'était pas un enfant il avait 18 ans et
cette année le char et 10 n a fait
stéphane richard est là mais un stéphane
dion shania loire dont 46 02 au bois là
non plus pas de nom mais le temps c'est
nul parce qu'on va mettre tout le monde
mal à l'aise et c'est ridicule j'ai pas
envie de le voir donc si on sait pas une
bonne petite oie maintenant donc si
c'est pour qu'on est obligé de le faire
c'est quoi est ce que vous voulez voir
stéphane échanges finalisant
il ne faut pas jouer avec ses nerfs je
viens tu es sûr que tu veux pas le
moment je veux parler je n'ai aucune
envie de le voir changer
je vais parler avec luis henao comme les
données de cette chance 2 1 cadeau pour
toi chevau-légers pas fait de procéder
s'excuse t il à un cadeau pour toi
julien du court bouillon
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
si on en est arrivé là pour que pendant
trois ans qu'un type de courbe où il
accompagne alors est-ce que vous est-ce
qu'il est là donc il y reste
on dit à stéphane de rentrer chez lui
mais rompt les rangs de chaises et
stéphane richard je sais c'est qu'ils
cherchent c'est très bien je veux pas
qu'ils rentrent ça soit qu'ils
s'aimaient pas sur la photo déjà celles
auxquelles sur la basse et stéphane
pichat mais c'est stéphane non non non
non non bonsoir stéphane c'est lui oui
mais oui certaines fans comprendront
enfin des gens sérieux
messi alors bien stéphane meca quelque
chose à te dire moi j'ai rien à lui dire
non et non stéphane je suis désolé je
suis désolé fred c'est vrai qu'à
l'époque déjà s'il te plaît les frais
des machins va discuter à dire je m'en
vais après tu es toi tu sortiras mais
j'ai compris j'ai entendu ce que tu as
dit mais voilà on était jeunes on
n'était pas très malin
les concertos et oui sans doute voilà je
suis désolé je pensais que je pensais
qu'avec le temps et oui et quand ils
m'ont contacté ok mais bon voilà et
après je pensais je pensais pas qu'ils
géraient alors vous avez un cadeau pour
julien ben oui j'avais amené un petit
cadeau pour jusqu'à ce que tu maintenant
je veux presser au galop je suis
absolument ce que ces femmes et ces
femmes ouais mais c'est pas bien c'est à
dire si elle est celle d'hier et on en
parlera après les jo la terreur pour
vous dire franchement c'est du coup mais
c'est vrai est ce que tu fais
rooney fait une vanne ses fans tu veux
tu excusé auprès de julien bajeux d un
peu oui je l' ai déjà fait je suis
vraiment désolé on était jeunes on était
au lycée mais c'est ça tu es sur koné ou
et en fait on voudrait dire voilà non et
ça c'est vrai on profite de cette saison
voilà il faut le dire voilà ses niveaux
d'avant
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je souhaitais a bien joué
[Applaudissements]
la comédie optionnel alors début on
voulait profiter de ça avec julien parce
que on avait entendu plein de trucs de
harcèlement voilà on voulait ça rentre
dans la tête des gens visiblement bien
toi tu as inventé steenwerck à de jeunes
très bien dit sion qui nous regardent et
qui sont victimes sur facebook ali
terrible c'est sûr il est bien rare
seulement à l'école les vad exeo on
s'est servi de cette blague pour dire
voilà les mecs ça peut traumatiser un
mec
mine de rien et je vous le dis arrêtez
de voile à vannes voilà toute l'année
des mecs tous ensemble à la junior
serait peut être vrai son histoire mine
de rien il aurait été traumatisée et
franchement rigoler avec un ensemble
mais rigolez pas les uns contre les
autres sectes voit là franchement c'est
une solution qui l'a vu éclore ya plein
de jeunes qui nous regardent vous dit il
ya plein de jeunes qui nous contactent
sur les réseaux sociaux que ce soit
julien ou mois et ce soir on a eu cette
idée régulière pour dire voilà les
jeunes s'il vous plait ne le faite pas
arrêter de voir celer [ __ ] qui fait
ensemble penser à rigoler ensemble et
non pas je le redis les uns contre les
autres
voilà c'est hyper important et tous les
jeunes qui nous regardent et les parents
aussi si vous fait harceler
s'il ya un mec dans votre classe qui
vous chouchoute soul toute la journée
ont-ils vous valez il faut le dire à vos
parents ça râle et voilà il faut parler
tout de suite ou à vos professeurs ou
aux directeurs ou à vos parents même en
patois et je vous le dis il faut arrêter
ça tout de suite parce que ça peut vous
traumatiser et je vous le dis à des
trucs très très grave il ya déjà des
voix il ya des choses graves qui se
passe autour de ça il y en a de plus en
plus et en ce moment voilà je vous le
dis je reçois un tas de messages qui a
plein de gens qui se tourne vers moi
alors je peux pas tout tous vous aider
mais les juges voilà je vous écoute et
je vous écouterai toujours les chéris
mais voilà je vous le dis par les oms
est très présente
merci